[Musique]
Salut. Aujourd'hui, on va se faire
une vidéo qui sort des sentiers battus,
puisqu'on va parler du
Hand Spinner.
Alors, attention...
Ça tourne !
Action !
T'as compris le jeu de mots ?
[Musique Générique]
Alors, c'est une vidéo qui va être
sûrement un peu plus courte
et plus rapide que d'habitude,
mais là je vais vous parler du
Hand Spinner
vous savez ce que c'est, je ne vais pas
vous représenter cet objet.
Mais il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant à savoir.
D'où vient cet objet ?!
Comment, du jour au lendemain,
quelqu'un a inventé un Hand Spinner ?
La personne qui a inventé cet objet,
c'est une femme et elle s'appelle
Catherine Herringer.
[Accent Anglais] Herringer.
Ça dépend si tu le prononces
dans sa langue natale,
puisque c'est une américaine.
Bien avant que ce jouet
explose sur Internet,
en partie grâce à Dc Nozman
et plein d'autres personnes,
Catherine l'avait inventé en 1997.
Elle avait déposé un brevet,
un vrai brevet d'invention
qui s'appelle le Spinning Toy,
dont le seul but est de s'occuper
les doigts en le faisant tourner.
Du Hand Spinner quoi...
Et, à la base, tenez vous bien,
elle avait inventé ça
pour pouvoir jouer avec sa fille
qui était malade.
Donc, elle a cherché, en vain, une activité
qui pouvait les relier ensemble,
où elles pouvaient jouer ensemble,
ça n'existait pas
elle l'a inventé.
Ça c'est malin.
Sa fille, qui avait 7 ans à l'époque,
avait, malheureusement, une myasthénie.
Donc, elle invente ce jouet.
Elle dépose le brevet.
Elle le propose à des marques
comme Hasbro et d'autres marques
qui refusent le jouet. En fait,
ça ne les intéresse pas du tout.
Et, en 2005,
elle ne renouvelle pas le brevet,
qui coûte 400$ par an.
En fait, quand tu déposes un brevet, il faut payer
tous les ans pour que le brevet soit maintenu.
Et elle ne le renouvelle pas,
non pas parce qu'elle n'y croit plus,
mais simplement parce qu'elle a
de graves problèmes financiers
et qu'elle n'arrive pas à le payer.
Le jouet est sorti de l'ombre.
A complètement explosé,
au point qu'il y a des demandes qui
n'arrivent pas à être satisfaites
en ce moment dans les magasins.
Et il y a même des endroits,
tellement c'est fort,
où on l'interdit !
Des écoles où c'est interdit...
Il y a le site spinnerlist.com,
que je vous invite à visiter,
qui recense même les écoles
où c'est interdit aux États-Unis.
C'est quand même 32% des écoles !
Le magasine TheGuardian
est allé l'interviewer récemment,
et a pu constater, en fait, à quel point
c'était compliqué
elle n'arrive même pas à payer
sa facture de téléphone ;
elle ne perçoit rien.
Aucun droit ! Rien du tout !
Sur tous les dérivés, d'ailleurs,
sur tous les Hand Spinners qui existent
et qui sont inventés, en ce moment,
quotidiennement.
Ça l'a tellement traumatisée
qu'elle a fait des recherches et
alors, je n'ai pas ses sources,
mais elle, elle a constaté qu'il y a seulement
3% des créateurs, comme ça, d'idées
qui perçoivent de l'argent plus tard.
Alors qu'au final, son jouet,
son invention, son idée !
est partout !
Que ça fait un tabac commercial.
Que c'est en train d'être utilisé pour
aider à la concentration d'enfants autistes.
Et elle, elle a un fille qui est encore
malade aujourd'hui,
de cette maladie auto-immune
qui est la Myasthénie,
et elle ne touche rien !
C'est ouf ou pas ?
Là, je sais, je ne suis pas en train de faire
une vidéo habituelle sur cette chaîne.
Comme j'ai un peu de personnes
qui m'écoutent,
et peut-être que vous kiffez,
vous aussi, le Hand Spinner,
je voulais vous raconter l'histoire
de ce jouet
et surtout, que Catherine a lancé un site
en fait, une espèce de Crowdfunding
pour sortir le jouet d'origine.
Je sais, vous avez sûrement déjà
un Hand Spinner.
Mais vous pouvez aller faire un don
sur le Kickstarter qu'elle a lancé.
En contrepartie, vous recevrez le vrai
Hand Spinner d'origine
tel qu'il a été pensé.
Mais, si vous en avez déjà un
et que vous n'en avez pas besoin d'autre,
vous pouvez faire comme moi
et ne demander aucune contrepartie
et mettre une petite somme.
Et il n'y a que 96 contributeurs.
Elle a besoin de 23.000 $ pour
lancer le projet,
et il y a juste 6.000$
Je trouve ça dingue !
Je me dis que, si toutes les personnes
qui ont acheté un Hand Spinner
comprennent un peu le mécanisme et ne versent
que 1€ sans demande de contribution aucun,
mais elle le dépasse de ouf son plafond !
Donc, j'avais envie de vous en parler.
Voilà.
J'espère que vous apprécierez
quand même la vidéo,
même si c'est particulier.
J'espère qu'elle ne sera pas trop
dislikée et, au contraire,
qu'elle sera likée et partagée.
Ce n'est pas un grand engagement
mais c'est juste une pensée pour quelqu'un
qui a vraiment besoin
qui a une petite fille malade,
qui s'est fait spolier d'une idée
qui lance une idée par derrière
mais qui n'arrive pas à la financer...
Je pense que nous, à notre petite échelle,
en mettant 1€ sur le délire,
on peut l'aider.
Mais aujourd'hui c'était une vidéo
supplémentaire !
Il ne faut pas la voir comme une vidéo
en remplacement d'une vidéo habituelle
mais comme une vidéo en plus !
Et si vous voulez lui mettre un petit
message de soutien en français ou en anglais
dans les commentaires,
n'hésitez pas à le faire
je ferai un screen de tout ça
et je lui enverrai avec un petit don
auquel vous n'avez pas à participer,
je le ferai moi-même.
Allez, on se retrouver jeudi
pour la prochaine vidéo
jeudi soir, un peu tard je pense...
Ciao.
[Musique générique de fin]